this video contains major spoilers for
attack on titan season 4 part 2 episode
4. if you are not caught up with the
series i advise doing that before
watching this video you've been warned
rise up jagerists salute from your
hearts and belch your boisterous battle
cries as we witness aaron make his way
to the top of the list of anime's most
dastardly diabolical and inexplicably
devious schemers of all time
the characters who cooked up a secret
plan and plot twist so comprehensive and
mind-boggling that it has you
questioning everything you've ever
believed
that makes it feel like aaron knew every
single thought you ever had before you
even had it which honestly isn't too far
from the truth
and yes you all know what i'm talking
about
aaron literally manipulated everything
while everyone was playing checkers
aaron was not just playing chess but
somehow inventing chess at the same time
across time itself aaron schemed up
until this point exactly how he wanted
all to go in one of the most insane plot
twists of all time in anime
and there is a certain art to making a
great plot twist a number of factors
that both keep readers and viewers from
guessing that it'll happen
and making sure the moment when it's
revealed is incredibly impactful
not just because of the plot twist in
information but the setting build up
performance all of it is very
fundamentally important
let's talk about it in the first step
which is what i call the art of
distraction
you can't stop people from making
theories
the hints the author has dabbled
throughout the series are always there
and what attack on titan mastered
perfectly is distracting us from
thinking about it up until the very last
moment
the reveal of the attack titan's actual
ability was so powerful because it was
completely unexpected
why is that
i'm sure people could have thought that
there was far more to the attack titan
but why wasn't it a big cause for
concern among the community why wasn't
it a big theory
looking in hindsight there's a
specificity to almost every titan's
ability
the armored titans defense colossal
titan size jaw titans
well jaws
cart tightens mobility and longevity
warhammer tightens creation of
structures the female titans hardening
and ability to crystallize the beast
titan's hairiness of course and then the
attack titan is
what just a naked dude who can fight and
eventually learns how to harden
basically just copying the female titan
why wouldn't we suspect there was more
to it
well it's quite simple
since the end of season two aaron's
attack titan has been far overshadowed
by the founding titan
in season one and two titan shifters are
still kind of unclear and we don't
really have a reason to question the
attack titan or think more about it the
show is simple and still picking up at
this point
by season 3 once we really start world
building the focus shifts to trying to
figure out what the founding titan even
is
we figure out its powers how it played a
role in the rice family and king of
paradise's vow against violence we're
finding that the founding titan is
arguably the most important and powerful
titan out there and aaron has it
in season 4 what's important is now
finding out how aaron can access this
power now that we know what it is the
series continues to hold the founding
titan and its relevance to the story in
the limelight
frankly by this point in attack on titan
it purposefully makes it feel like the
attack titan is more of a means so that
aaron can fight while the founding titan
is the real power he holds
that the attack titan is really just a
supplement if anything
which is certainly true to some extent
but the show is constantly distracting
us from the craziest power of them all
if you want to see another example of
attack on titan using this art of
distraction more look at the second
biggest plot twist when reiner and
berthold reveal their identities as
titans
in the episodes leading up to this we
have a super intense fight for the
survey corps as well as the reveal that
ymir was a titan shifter
it was crazy to see that there's another
shifter it's the first one we've seen
since annie we're left wondering how she
got her power what her goal is is it
like annie's or is she different
and then isayama surprises us
immediately with something far more
insane
we were so distracted by other things
other important things
ymir's story and status as a titan
shifter is super important just like how
the founding titan is also super
important right now
it's not like we're being distracted by
little trivial moments or purposeful red
herrings
but the big reveals are always being
saved for the perfect time amidst the
chaos of it all
and it takes a particular skill and
storytelling and writing to find those
little spaces those ideal moments and
this is part of why reiner and
birdhole's plot twist was also amazing
[Music]
now returning to the case of aaron's
twist even in the most recent episodes
zooming into the moments before the
reveal this theory of distracting the
audience still goes but this time it's
not with the founding titan really it's
it's distracting us with zeke
the cliffhanger of episode 3 left us
believing that zeke tricked aaron into
giving him the power of the founding
titan
allowing zeke to use it solely according
to his own will and as a bearer of royal
blood
and honestly just because of how
ambiguous the founding titan and ymir
are at this point you don't really have
a place to question this
like yeah you might think that aaron has
something else up his sleeve but it kind
of seems like he's trapped at this point
cause you don't really know any better
and then in episode 4 up until the point
of the reveal it's a total slow burner
we're exposed to a lot of dialogue and
even more insight into zeke's belief
about grisha and how he brainwashed
aaron into believing his doctrine of
wanting to free elder from the marlians
once again i'll emphasize that this
distraction per se
is very very important for character
building and fleshing out zeke and
grisha's character it's as much a
distraction as it is a pretty important
plot point ever since zeke and aaron
spoke at shiganshina the first thing
zeke ever told aaron was how grisha
brainwashed him
this show is leading us to believe that
zeke is really running this scene in his
attempt to show aaron exactly how grisha
molded him their discussion about their
father distracting them from the truth
that was yet to
come and then we get to the monumental
scene
and first just take note of how
beautiful the soundtrack is here the
build-up and just how menacing the
orchestral music behind grisha and
frida's discussion is as it gradually
gets more and more hostile
it's building up to the moment we all
know is coming where grisha eats the
royal family
he says very subtly almost like it's not
important that the attack titan's true
power is the ability to see its future
bearer's memories
and you're thinking
what does that mean
what can grisha see then how does this
change things
dozens of thoughts swirl in our heads
alongside the anticipation of the
violence and massacre of eating the
royal family
with the music belting in our ears along
with hiroshi's toshida's absolutely
incredible voice acting and performance
here there's so much going on it's
almost like over stimulation
and then it stops
just like when reiner and burt holtz
were revealed attack on titan perfectly
uses silence to make the moment of
reveal strike clear and poignant
and then the music returns just for a
moment
the frightening villain piano theme just
slightly hinting at the devious twist
that is to come
grisha falls to his knees and claims
that he can't kill children
wait
what
the panic sets in
the royal family screaming at frida to
kill him zeke asking what's going on and
how it could even be possible that the
past is changing right now in front of
his eyes
and then it happens
you realize
this isn't some different version of the
past that's occurring like zeke thinks
this is the one story everyone's been
living
this is history this
is fact
one that aaron made happen
we see the true power of the attack
titan come to life as aaron grabs
grisha's shoulder and tells him exactly
what he must do
the beautiful contrast here between
aaron's stone cold determined face and
grisha's fear and wavering commitment
it's clear that grisha would never do
this if aaron were not there
did you forget what you came here to do
your sister who got eaten by dogs
your wife was turned into a titan
you don't stop here
you don't stop in death you don't stop
even after death
it's horrifically beautiful everything
about this moment
not only does it shock us to our core
with the power of the attack titan and
aaron's ability to actually change the
past with it but it also shows us the
unwavering and indomitable mindset that
aaron carries with him
the reason zeke thought grisha
brainwashed aaron was because he was
carrying out the will of aaron himself
the subtle line here but grisha says how
he killed the entire royal family except
the father and us knowing that aaron
needs the father in order to meet
historia and make contact with the
founding titan it's more than just aaron
changing the past too he's molded this
story into what he wanted it to be
he doesn't show grisha all his memories
only what he needs to to make sure he
follows exactly what he says
it's insanely manipulative and almost
unbelievable
what grisha could not do
aaron could
to achieve his goal to take away their
freedom before they take hours this is
the culmination of aaron's character up
until this point it's something that's
been hinted at since season 1 that aaron
will never submit to anyone
this has nothing to do with his titan or
what cage or chains you might shackle
him with aaron proves that he stops at
nothing in this single moment
just like what grisha says
only aaron will get what he wants
the beauty of this perfect plot twist
is that the plot itself
was always written by aaron
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses
you